you know I think that that kind of help
[ __ ] could help you tone it down I mean
I pretty much mate mostly do white
people [ __ ] these days you know I used
to do a lot of you know multicultural
activities in the day you know we used
to pop off a little bit and get a little
bit Latino and even look I get Russian
sometimes with some of these ladies but
you know now these days I'm doing I'm
keeping I'm keeping things Caucasian you
know I turn up a little bit sometimes if
there's like a if it's a playoff game oh
you know I do appreciate you calling it
sounds like you that strong bro you
strong enough to get through this take a
week off the gym and work out on what's
inside man just start working out on it
the first day you might not feel it but
you'll get there you know you'll get
there man
because that's the manliest thing that's
the heaviest weights dude is whatever's
weighing on our soul bro I swear and I
know I need to work harder on it myself
I mean work with a battered wives club
or of victims of violence you know that
might show you the end product of you
know if you do feel like you have anger
and violence issues at times it could
show you the end product of that and
help you ward against um you know have a
stop in your head into your mind you'll
have an end idea of what what the
effects of that behavior look like but
damn dog if there's one thing I'm afraid
of do to snakes if there's another thing
it's Hardy brothers do that are angry
I'm saying this anybody get in there and
lift the weights but sometimes the
strongest thing you can do is lift that
[ __ ] that's off your brain you know
get in there and work out that muscle
because that's so that's the irony of it
is this sometimes we get off yourself
physically so in tune but all we really
want is to get that weight off of our
chest off of our shoulder you said you
might have been bullied growing up or
whatever you know I got attacked by
animals on my birthday man I don't know
if that's bullied but but it's it's wild
you know and I don't want to see you out
there head-butting children like that
man that did me you know maybe he was
you maybe he had anger
and he never dealt with them and then
there he is you know 15 years later
head-butting schoolchildren for vodka
you know I'm not saying that could be
you but you know if you don't get into
the gym that brain gym that soul gym and
start to figure out what it is
things can get squirrely this.g pigs
walk it up that laptop today um he's so
wild boy come on dude he's trying to use
her he's trying to use a Photoshop man
he trying to use photo he trying to use
Photoshop v20 I'm so tired look at that
look at them holes in my face that's my
eyes all right man thank you guys for
checking out this clip and if you want
to see another clip then you can look at
this clip or this clip either one of
these so did you pick one or he's still
just watching me do this cuz this is
alarming